foreign
in Chicago what's up Josue
hey man are you there I'm yeah I'm here
man what are you what are you up to
dude I'm just uh Rock and rolling right
that's what we're all doing
excellent hey we all are so what's up
brother how can I help
hey man thank you for taking my call it
almost sounds unreal to be here but um I
have my stuff written out just so I can
keep my thoughts from being scattered
can I read my question then I can read
the details is that okay absolutely man
all right man so my question is how do I
get unstuck from where I've been in Life
or what feels like the last decade and
I'm gonna have some stuff right here so
feel free to interrupt me whenever you
want
over the last several years I feel like
more and more become the kind of person
who can't follow through on his goals
and plans I'm easily distracted and feel
like I've become addicted to my phone in
media often numbing out on it and
seeking to entertain and distract myself
instead of doing the things I should I
should do and I wasted so much time this
way I procrastinate on my job often
because of impulsive distractions and
then I find myself stressed trying to
get the minimum accomplished but I end
up producing what I feel as mediocre
work
I gained around 35 pounds since I've
been married and I failed to lose any of
their or stick to consistent exercise or
eating I don't always like what I see in
the mirror and I wish I looked different
I feel like there's very little
disciplining self-control in my life
whenever I get to a new place for a new
season I say I'm going to change and
become more responsible focus more
productive but it's not long before I
end up doing the same thing and telling
a friend or a counselor the exact same
thing that I've been starting with for
the last few years I feel like my life
could be so much more but it's not and I
get frustrated with myself that I
haven't yet changed and that I keep
wasting it away
hmm
how old are you man
I'm 30 years old 30. oh you've been
married
uh
uh three and a half years about tell me
about that
my marriage yeah
um
I mean my wife is
more than I could ask for man she saw
her she's amazing she's what I call I
always joke around this issues high
functioning she she has a plan and she
executes it well
um we have a seven month old well she's
eight months today I think
um daughter first daughter and she's
beautiful too but
um since she was born life has been kind
of upside down
um just you know trying to adjust to a
newborn
um
our marriage I would say it's good I
threw it like a seven or eight out of
ten I have to rate it um we had to work
through our stuff
um how can they how
so if you were building a building and
it had four steel posts in the ground
yeah
how could two of those posts be
incredible
the other two of those posts be weak and
crumbling
and unsettled in their Foundation
yet you tell me the building is seven
out of ten
eight out of ten
ah well how are you so good at being
married yet you think so little of
yourself in every other area
I was I was wondering if that's what you
were going to ask me eventually
um
I don't know man I let me ask you this
let me ask you this that's kind of an
unfair question is yeah sure what is
being unmotivated and undisciplined and
running around like your hair is on fire
all the time what does that get you
because it's getting you something
I mean so I as long as I can remember I
always play first and work hard later
and I feel like I don't get stuff done
unless there's a deadline or a fire
under my seat like unless that hammers
coming down it's like oh it's okay it'll
get done one day
and so uh letting things sit till the
last minute until I'm stressed out is
it's good external motivation because I
feel like there's not a lot of internal
motivation if that makes sense why not
I don't know because I guess it goes
back to I just I I know you know why you
know why just tell me
[Applause]
because it's more fun to do what's easy
yeah I know but listen you're you're
choosing and you've probably heard me
say this uh you're choosing your heart
yeah
because like getting up and getting your
crap done and doing work with excellence
and exercising and
you know all that stuff
that's hard
yes and completely bumming out and
hating yourself who the guy you see in
the mirror is hard too so you're
choosing one part or the other one's not
easier than the other
right why are you choosing that one
it's getting you something that's when I
get to the the core of it where does it
get you
what's it protecting you from
pity for mothers doing hard things I
think
um
but the life you're choosing is so much
harder than mine
right yeah
um
you know John has not
I have not asked myself that that
question that specifically I'm sorry I'm
a bit no it's all good it's okay so I
want you to keep
laughs
why haven't you smashed your phone
why haven't you smashed your phone and
said enough
because I keep justifying finding some
reason why I need it no you there's
something about the situation that you
enjoy that you like that you're
benefiting from that's what I'm trying
to get to
I I like being entertained I like I like
I I grew up uh being a gamer and over
time I've let go of my games and my wife
when I married her she said I don't want
to be married to someone who doesn't
play games I was like all right cool
I'll sell all my stuff but as you know
the world has transitioned to everything
being on one's phone right and so I
might I feel like it's absolutely untrue
oh okay fair I feel like my addiction to
what was at one point games at one point
I even also wrestled at the point of
addiction I feel like that's transferred
now to Media
um I've traded out one thing for another
so anytime anytime you say the word
Addiction
I want you to think of Relationship
Challenge
okay and your body is trying to duct
tape over relationship pain somewhere
okay here's the thought that just came
to my mind
um I have noticed that it's when I have
a hard or difficult situation at home to
deal with my
typical response of dealing with hard
negative feelings is sending them out
exactly and you've been doing that since
you were one kid
right and so a memory that just came go
ahead
well no just the the memory that came to
my mind was I remember being
nine or ten and I'm being at home and I
was alone at home with my dad and I
could hear my dad in his room on the
phone talking to a woman that wasn't my
mom and I as a nine or ten year old
understood that that was not cool and
not okay
but I didn't know how to con I didn't
want to confirm my deck this is weird
and so I just remember saying the easy
thing to do is just to go bury my head
in my video games in my room that was my
way of numbing out the discomfort of
knowing my dad was being unfaithful to
my mom
um I have no it's just uh the same
pattern how many times have you talked
about that
uh with my friends
a few times okay several times here's
the word that comes to mind for you
powerless
when you feel powerless and your wife
comes through just like a boss dude just
crushing it
yeah
you feel powerless when your boss comes
in and says you're gonna do this you're
gonna show up you're gonna do this you
instantly turn into a nine-year-old kid
again
and we don't have any buddies in your
life and you've outsourced all your
relationships to text messages and
emojis
your body feels completely powerless
because it cannot do anything without
close connection to other people
and so when I ask you what you're
getting from this you're getting the
avoidance of feeling reality
yes your body your body's trying to take
care of you the best it can
and it's going to do that in the short
term and kill you in the long term
yeah
yeah I feel that already
is that fair
yeah that that makes sense I I I've not
been told the word powerless before but
that makes sense I don't like feeling
like my life when reality feels like
it's spinning out I just say well this
is too hard screw this and I just go in
my mouth so I need you to to know that
when your body feels anxious when your
body feels disconnected
and you avoid it it actually gets what
it wants so what does it do it makes
that anxiety stronger
this is neurochemistry it makes it more
powerful
the longer you avoid the longer you go
the longer you just put your head down
and
um instead of snorting something you
pick up your your stupid video game
controller or your cell phone
yeah the stronger it gets
what happened that made you want to call
me did something happen
yeah I I had an argument with my wife
that morning and I I reacted really
strongly
um I raised my voice I've never full on
yelled at my wife but I raised my voice
to her and why and I just
ah like what happened she okay so
basically she sent me some texts the
night before and I was coming out of a
meeting and I because I was in the
meeting I I didn't check them I got home
and she was hey can you read a messages
I sent you yeah yeah sure the next
morning she's like did you read the text
I was like look I I forgot to do it it's
no big deal she feels that that's our
way of staying connected I feel like
she's asking me clean that's not that
important so
this irritation this rage kicked in my
heart that I feel like I've been dealing
with also the last few months and I just
said why are you I didn't say but I was
like why are you freaking out about
something so inconsider and then it just
became this giant argument and she
walked away upset and I was upset and so
then it just became a low day and I
realized my life is not what I wanted to
be okay because I'm not what I want to
be I want you to reframe what your wife
did
and she tried to use
the streets you walk on which are
digital electronic as a way to connect
with you
So when you say it wasn't a big deal I
want you to think of her putting her
arms around you with one hand on the
back of your neck and putting her face
up against yours and just breathing for
a minute
that's what she was trying to do but
you're never there
and even when you're sitting right next
to her you're not there
when you're in your home holding your
kid you are not there
yeah and so she's trying to reach out so
to say it's inconsequential is not cool
because it was yeah
yeah so
after following this phone call I'm
gonna give you some things you are not
allowed to say anymore okay
okay you cannot say the words I can't
because that's not true
okay the words you're going to use from
this forward are I am choosing
my phone over my new baby
I am choosing my phone over my wife
I am choosing my phone over my health
okay
those are the words I'm choosing my
phone over respect and dignity
I'm choosing a video game controller
over peace
these are all choices you are making
and your body's trying to is I mean it's
got a vested interest in this because if
not you got to deal with the fact that
you feel really powerless
that you have a wife who loves you and
wants to connect with you and you still
feel like a nine-year-old trying to hide
yeah
Fair
yeah that's fair man
so here's what we're going to start with
uh that's that's number one is you're
not gonna say the words I can't anymore
you're gonna say the words I choose the
second thing is got it is I want you to
choose who you're gonna be
none of your plans or none of your
activities or none of your I I promise
none of that works if you don't have a
fundamental shift in your identity who I
am
mm-hmm
and so I'm a guy
who values people over technology
I am a guy who come hell or high water
takes care of his body I'm a good
Steward of my body so that I can be the
husband I need to be so that I can be
the dad I need to be
fair and I don't know what those are
going to be I think it would be really
wise for you to sit down with your wife
and say hey I'm working on some new
identity
you've known me for a long time you love
me we've created a human together we're
building a life together will you help
me through some of these things
the third thing is you got to develop an
identity with your wife here's Who We
Are Gonna Be here's the home we are
building
and only after you've done those three
things no more saying I can't you're
gonna say I choose you're gonna build a
personal set of identity here's Who I Am
Number Three here's who we are only then
can you get to the strategy part or the
action part
okay you know what that is
smash your phone
sell your your your video game consoles
throw your TV in the garbage can because
you're gonna lose your wife over it
yeah you're gonna grow up with a kid
wondering what was so bad about me that
I couldn't compete with a little five
inch by three inch box
yeah
now can you really smash your phone no
but I mean I could but yeah
but you can say the phone never comes
out of my car and then you know what
you're gonna be so awkward and bored and
weird for about three months because
you're gonna be sitting in your house
with no device and you're gonna be
staring at a little lump of kid that's
taking all your money and kind of ruin
your sex life and you're gonna be
looking at your wife being like uh hey
what's up and we're going to be I don't
even know how to do this
that's the path forward
okay you're gonna take lots of walks and
you're going to with your wife and you
take lots of walks with your kids and
you can do it together and you're gonna
start cooking at home because what else
you're gonna do you might start
exercising and what you're gonna find in
three months is that every single thing
about your life has changed
so here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
send you four or five packs of questions
for humans and what these are they're
just tools for a guy who turns his phone
off
and then goes what do I do now and I
want you to use these with your wife I
want you to use these with yourself I
want you to use these with people you
invite over to the house
and by the way be weird man just invite
people over it might be a disaster who
cares
invite them over
and I want you to to to stop with the
beating up post way that's not work
you've been angry and
um pissed on Josue for 20 years now stop
it's not working
when your body wants to numb out I just
want you to pause for a second and say
hey what are you trying to protect me
from
and then let's go into that storm not
away from it
and then just back up and man I got some
skills I got to learn I've never had to
be present before because I've been
hiding since I was nine
I'm gonna start practicing being present
and practice learning how to talk to my
wife and I promise she's been waiting
for this moment for a long long time
tell her everything I just told you
let her walk alongside you I'm proud of
you brother
tomorrow the light's going to be a
little bit brighter
and um
if you have some some courage man your
life's Gonna Change stay on the line and
Jenna will get you hooked up